flooding that anyone can remember in
volunteer Colin Taylor is going
house-to-house so how many people have
you rescued now oh they put the question
mostly two dozen the water rose so fast
here many people are stranded we didn't
quite this is the sitting room in this
home the family have tried to salvage
what they can but it is hopeless we have
he has a big cider crates which he lived
step on to her upstairs windows those
who've decided to stay look down
helpless on roads that have turned to
rivers right cold
Karen Smith driveway is under feet of
water she tells me she couldn't leave
even if she wanted to so much here has
been destroyed and it's the second time
these homes have been flooded in the
last four months this is one of the
worst affected neighborhoods people's
possessions rubbish floating down the
street you can see how deep it is I'm
using a pole just to make sure it
doesn't suddenly drop off but of course
what's happening here are searching
policy questions for the government
about how you protect places like this
at the time of a climate emergency and
more unpredictable weather systems
in other parts of the country the
cleanup has already begun this
supermarket in Worcester has been
devastated obviously we have Kerry last
weekend it got closed again and luckily
it didn't happen but here we are again
and it was Kira's super soaking that
laid the sodden ground for the power of
Dennis with two monster storms so close
together many flood prone areas didn't
stand a chance
they played warden came round and warned
us that it was going to come quite high
and then the fire brigade came and said
you really should leave because it's
going to be higher than it's been before
but so we thought were last time we left
that it went down the next morning so we
thought we'll be ok yeah it was scary
and all of us like we got all the
drawers and that that we could but
there's still things that you're
thinking oh god if we got those
passports and all of this but there's
nothing you can do but I had the waders
but mum and grandma didn't have anything
to go downstairs it's freezing so it's
not even worth it what's gone is gone
and can be replaced can it
in York there are fears the river ooze
which is swollen and angry may rise even
further flood defences have been set up
around the city for people living on
nature's frontline it is an anxious wait
the Environment Agency still has
hundreds of flood warnings in place much
of the country is a patchwork of lakes
levels are not going to change hugely
over the next 24-48 hours and that
presents another problem in itself where
we have got flooded homes and businesses
and flooded roads the situation isn't
going to improve very quickly back in
Herefords and the rescue operations are
continuing more rain and gale force
winds are predicted and that means more
wet and misery
Alex Rossi Sky News